Holly from another school also math
teacher and started looking for videos
recently and is notice that I don't know
if you've noticed this a lot of my views
sometimes I break up into multiple parts
and I'll deliberately like I just in 10
minutes ago show you a right way and a
wrong way to do it but the when they're
in separate videos the right way
consistently gets more views of the
wrong ways which is not surprising
you're like why would I want to watch
the wrong way well I'll let you think
about the answer that question because
there's a reason why I show you the
wrong way and right way like I'm about
to do now you also withdraw your diagram
well done to your credit everyone has a
diagram okay not so much to your credit
something of a grounds are pretty small
but luckily for you here less than with
the UM the shadow diagram you can kind
of get away with it on this one as well
as much information put on there not
that you necessarily knew that the
beginning of the question I think you
were just lazy anyway let me just
rehearse what I think most of you and
certainly me when I was knowing your 11
12 would have done to a purchase
question you draw your intersection okay
and then you start to account for your
information and he tends to be the way
that you do it so I'm in a sequential
way so you look at it says um there's a
motor car okay and it's away from you
and there's a train also away from the
intersection right and they're moving at
different speeds so you write their
speeds on the diagram and you say 40
commoners per hour and 50 km/h is this
looking familiar on your diagram right
there anyway and then it says they're
very way for the intersection they are
40 and 30 kilometers respectively from
the intersection at a particular time so
then you're looking so okay well that
makes this distance here that makes this
40 and that makes this 30
okay and then it is mm-hmm at what rate
is the distance between them changing an
hour later oh ok and in the distance
between them I've already got that
that's the hypotenuse oh you call that
next is whatever okay and now you look
at you okay I have accounted for all the
information in the question now I'd
better begin putting on so all you know
using calculus language to afford two
equations that I can use to solve this
thing right do you think okay what do i
want i want DX 1 butene no problems so
far okay i'll most of you have that
written down and then you think we'll
okay clearly I have to get this in terms
of some other rates that I have well
what are these things okay I better give
him some names right ah this is this is
a car and it's this this length is
changing so let me call this lake which
is changing and call it capital C okay
that's not a lot of bad babe for it okay
now this is a trade so I'm going to call
it capital T maybe you I'm not fond of
having dt of dt but you better get used
to it because whenever you talk about
temperature it's always going to be a
capital T and you get a fair few of
those so okay I now know that DC on dt
that should be well it's increasing is
it so it's positive money and this is
the awkwardly no dt on dt which is 30
anything home okay all right I need to I
need to relate these somehow don't know
the strategy we'd use in the past is you
for instance with the the base and the
height of that I'll trough that we were
looking at right there like where are we
these are related in some way aren't
they okay so i can use Pythagoras I
could do it a couple of different ways I
could say that I could go in this
direction I could go that way I try and
replace something over there but then
you hit hmm no wait not such a good idea
to replace X because we want that in our
final answer that's a good get rid of X
do you look at one of these guys
okay well this is the other side so I
can say t is equal to well it's a
shorter sides going to be the square
root of x squared minus C squared yeah
nothing my right so you think okay
that's that's good but then you like
caught on wait I need some derivative
here somewhere if for instance I wanted
to do some work with DSP and this how do
you differentiate this with respect to
tight I've got two variables they're
both changing okay hmm so this is a lot
a good way to approach it if you have
solved it this way it's my impossible it
is just extraordinarily awkward because
I need this that too many variables
approach because surprise surprise it
has too many variables okay so be this
is not a great way to approach it not so
said not necessarily wrong but there's
nothing one here that I've said which is
factually wrong it's just not a good
setup to actually solve for question
okay so how can I do this a bit better
right pas de problem was as we tried to
put information on the question we just
went through sentence by sentence letter
by letter number by number and started
putting things on there there's not
always the best way to go okay we also
expected that there would be a certain
strategy at the end that we're working
towards and it just didn't pan out for
us so I'm going to approach it a little
bit differently okay and you'll see
number one the way that I put
information on the diagram will be quite
different number two the strategy that I
end up with will also be different to
the previous questions i showing you
which is why i picking it out as an
example okay